[Music]
so
the rialto fire department is being sued
for a hundred million dollars do they
even have that much that'll just
bankrupt the fire department in the city
just the whole city's just burning you
gotta put all the fire trucks on offer
up to pay for that
that's true or just do independent
extinguishing work
imagine you're sitting there on an offer
up and you're like let's see if they
have fire trucks you know
i could get a japanese one import it if
you guys want yeah i do want how much
are they probably like less than 10 g's
really remember like the ones we saw at
the land cruiser uh museum yeah there's
other ones like that too you know how to
import japanese fire trucks i don't but
my friend owns a company that imports
this the k-van guys yeah does anybody
you have a batmobile guy i'm looking for
batman
i'm actually gonna i'm gonna buy a
batmobile batmobile guy yeah but first
he's gotta sell it for a plane okay i've
heard that
all right we'll talk about it after this
all right so it's a pretty interesting
reason got a car smuggling business
this is actually correct to say but it's
a lot deeper than this but yeah the
rialto fire department's being sued for
100 million over one coveted death
what
who the [ __ ] died was it like a
celebrity or somebody special not at all
and it's it's really gonna fire you up
the way this [ __ ] happened so fire
you up huh i didn't mean to do that but
i guess
all right so uh
you do it so much better than anthony
shut the [ __ ] up
just [ __ ] one time bro like let him
[ __ ] finish
jesus anthony shut the [ __ ] up or choke
on your [ __ ] protein powder
it is delicious
all right so
there's a 56 year old man who is at the
back of the rialto post acute center and
he was suffering a cardiac arrest and
you know how when that happens at
clinics or if it happens at like urgent
care they call the ambulance you know
so uh it's november 17.
this guy is at the other side of the
building in a room on a bed with no
wheels and the fire department is
standing outside saying no you got to
bring him outside we can't go in there
oh [ __ ] wait what why because of colvin
oh so everyone's just sticking
everyone's just sticking to whatever
their protocol is yes but even even if
common sense is should be like totally
overrides common sense yeah so there's
no other way to get to this guy unless
they go inside the building they're in
there fighting for this guy's life
trying to like they don't have you know
what it takes to do it successfully so
they're begging the fire department to
just come inside come inside the body
cam footage gets out and it shows the
fire the fire department guys and the
ambulance the paradise is standing
outside going no we got to bring him out
here protocol you got to bring them
outside because technically they're not
supposed to go in there but what if they
got covered that would be disaster
it depends
was this in the beginning of covid
because everyone was paranoid and and
everyone was acting [ __ ] weird bro
you're still wearing masks on the
[ __ ] airplanes i think there's it was
not in the beginning it was it was
november 17 so it was already you know
well underway oh by that time you still
paranoid you're a [ __ ] at that point
if that's the mandate that this city is
getting then yeah so uh that's tough i
love when nothing makes sense and people
were like that's the rules it's weird
huh
what do you want me to do
yeah and then if you question the rules
you're like so you want grandmas to die
you son of a [ __ ] so you like it when
grandmas die huh does it turn you on to
make you horny
[Laughter]
i want to meet that person king shame my
grandma death thing she saw this from
rialto
is rialto norcal yeah isn't it damn
because they're extra sensitive up there
well yeah as you go as you go north yet
oh no it's in san bernardino county
oh no that's weird because they're more
that's pretty hardened over there yeah
you see more trump flags out but not in
government right in government that's
true yeah government's different the
rule people like to put a mask on their
face and their head yeah so but not when
they're at parties that's when they
don't wear it no but still under their
nose while they're doing it though hold
your breath dude during the heat of the
pandemic i was training at this crossfit
gym close to my house and it's owned by
uh one of the assistant
um like fire chiefs of the city
and then i was like
oh it's cool like uh you guys don't have
to wear masks so it was easy for me to
train there because it was really hard
to train with the mask on and then he
was like yeah call this [ __ ] [ __ ]
and i was like oh [ __ ] that's tight and
then i was like what about like don't
you like have to go and like have all
these calls and pick people up from
houses and he was just like aren't you
scared and he goes nah he goes everyone
that i saw
um it just looked like a common cold so
i think for him he just got so like
jaded by it so i don't know i'm like
if people like if they were super scared
you know they probably would stay away
or i don't know if it's like standing
their ground or being defiant against
the government because you know people
were taking the stand at that time too
yeah
so it's just tough to know why they
didn't do that or they could have been
fired or penalized or some [ __ ] yeah
it's that's a weird thing because yeah
the attorney said the paramedics
continued to ignore the nurses who
begged them to help with life-saving
measures instead he said the paramedics
continue to just tell them they need to
bring the guy outside
while he's having cardiac arrest while
he's doing it and it wasn't until a cop
just said [ __ ] it and he ran in and
physically pushed the bed to the
entrance that's the paramedic started to
actually work on him but it was too late
i hope that these guys get sued to all
[ __ ] help
what i don't understand is that that's
crazy
i guess they it makes sense why they sue
the city or the the fire department
because of the fire department right but
i want suing to happen where the people
involved get penalized not the [ __ ] yeah
because these guys saved so many lives
the department probably helped some the
community and they're gonna bankrupt the
[ __ ] community instead of the idiots
who decided to [ __ ] make that
decision then and there i disagree i
want the the the
corporation to be sued or the the fire
department the pfizer the pfizer
department department
i don't want the individuals to be
harmed at all just to just take it take
it down yeah
they have paid vacation yeah because i
need to think about it but then let's
bankrupt the city
and the fire department and the police
department may be paid two-year
investigation when we figure out what
the hell went on in there because that's
a because that's a lawyer's strategy
that's a lawyer strategy let's go for
the people that have the most money um
that's it's always the lord the people
with the worst lawyers i always but i
want to [ __ ] see the ones that made
the decision suffer yeah your actions
that caused this [ __ ] like how bad
suffer
die
eye for an eye right you want the
government to die
so like maybe they're in a situation
where they need medical help and then
you're like sorry you turn your back
like this you induce a heart attack in
everyone and you go sorry bro covet
rules
i can't help you yeah but you're too far
away you're gonna have to crawl come
crawl
there's a sign somebody writes covid
rules yeah cope hit fruit with a z and
everyone who made those stupid coven
rules they also have to go through the
same thing and they have to suffer i'm
just i mean this i'm just glad i've
known those guys got covered cause that
would have been [ __ ] disastrous i
know right oh wow could have spread
through the whole station could dude
they could have had perosmia where you
can't smell and then all of a sudden
your taste comes back and everything
tastes like [ __ ] for a couple weeks do
you think these people have have his
death on their conscience like really or
do you think they're like nah we made
the right move i think they're like dude
covers literally the scariest thing that
ever has been produced by man and so
they're like thank [ __ ] christ i
didn't get coping god it didn't get
stuck in the hose
imagine putting out fires just really
just giving it coven
the whole building
that's the thing giving the [ __ ] that
guy's not coughing from the smoke he got
covered from the fire hose
this guy that passed away was he it was
his residence this happened or was it
like a nursing home no he was at the uh
the rialto post acute center so he's at
a different like
outfit yeah yeah yeah like it's not the
type of place that interesting yeah so
they did everything they were supposed
to do like they could have saved them
but you know that's so weird that like
they can't
cross that threshold yeah they're
[ __ ] vampires they could be invited
in
are you guys those people who don't
think people die to
coven man you guys gotta take cover
seriously come on that's what i'm saying
dude i don't know what's funny about
this [ __ ] don't let this be the thing
that divides us finally yeah yeah i
don't want to ruin the vibe into the
room so i'm gonna agree with you guys
dude i had a friend i had a friend who
got covered he lost both his arms and
legs had to be amputated holy [ __ ] wait
wait wait what
how come because of diabetes yeah yeah
well he had diabetes yeah but
yeah the covenant made him he did it
tipped it over though that's what did it
though yeah yeah it was the final
tipping point yeah not the not the 35
years of just bad eating no dude i also
know a guy who [ __ ] had his head
clean off and it had covered kids got
into a car accident
but he had coveted and so people were
wondering is that why you got into the
car accident it was multifactorial why
you died yeah yeah
this is one of the factors maybe nobody
knows yep so 100 million dollars is the
uh is the lawsuit
i guess it's not a big lawsuit you know
inflation and stuff oh yeah yeah you can
finally buy like three houses in la two
and a half maybe maybe two and a half
so what would a hundred million dollars
in today's money be ten years ago
i don't know a billion
what
that's what we need to do we'd be like
i'm suing you for 2010 value of 100
million dude but all right let's play a
little scenario what if your guys's
lawyer just got like 100 million dollars
what do you do buy luna dude no but we
it's our lawyer the lawyer got it yeah
they got it he didn't get any money oh
our lawyer got it but like put yourself
in this dream scenario it's like dude my
lawyer is about to be rich dude
it's like it's exciting it's like the
class action lawsuits right you get a
check it's like two dollars whoa
thank you for suing chase and then the
lawyer [ __ ] team got like a billion
payout or some [ __ ] and then they just
divvy out pennies to everybody involved
i just like to think like man good for
my lawyer dude
i'm so glad you're killing it
yeah dude i'm so happy my family member
died because now my lawyers got a
hundred million hey laura can you take
me to lunch she's like [ __ ] no am i all
right cool i'll talk to you later buddy